das hier wird es ganz schön wenn man
hier also ein check da kommt man erst
mal so ein relax station gibt es hier
vorne t
man sich erstmal eines seiner
lieblingsbücher ersuchen man es wird
bestimmt eine ganz spannende geschichte
bei dem ein oder anderen spieler oliver
pocher nimmt das mannschaftshotel der
deutschen nationalmannschaft persönlich
unter die lupe der comedian ist gerade
anlässlich der bevorstehenden fußball
weltmeisterschaft im gastgeberland katar
unterwegs und sich einen eindruck über
die vorbereitung und die unterbringung
zu machen
auf seinem instagram account nimmt er
seine fans mit auf entdeckungstour die
truppe rund um bundestrainer hansi flick
wird im zu larissa residieren einem
brandneuen fünf sterne hotel an der
nordspitze des landes sehr gutes hotel
fantastisch also auch wellness essen ich
hoffe die nationalmannschaft bringt ein
koch mit weil sonst dauert sehr lange
sehr sehr gut kein extra zucker keine
sachen die
chemisch hergestellt werden künstlich
hergestellt werden also wirklich super
geil
und wirklich wirklich allerdings extrem
nett und freundlich
hanses jungs kann man wellness oase mit
massageliegen selbstverständlich mit
einer eigenen pool bis zum
trainingsgelände sind es zehn kilometer
der zins ganz geschmeidige
42 grad er ist das ja ein bisschen
entspannter und aussichten hervorragend
hat ein bisschen was so von additiven
doch du weißt ja so nette kleine
häuschen und apartments
schön wenn's schön erfolg hilft gerne
zuvor möchte pocher das wüsten-emirat
ordentlich auf bei seiner tour durch das
land trug er in regenbogen binde am arm
solidarisiert sich mit der lgbt
community und bringt sich damit in
gefahr das emirat steht seit jahren
wegen seiner prekären menschenrechtslage
in der kritik immer wieder gibt es
berichte und vorwürfe dass frauen sowie
lesbische schwule bisexuelle transgender
geschlechtliche menschen diskriminiert
werden nach scharia recht gilt für
homosexuelle muslime in katar sogar die
todesstrafe
trauen wir dann auch gemäß gewalt
verkünden dass er